[Music]
Clayton English thank you for being on
the show man
been glad to be here Joel you know what
it is where much respect coming out here
and support in the movement no I
appreciate I like what you do it I've
been hearing about it and you know what
is this can I cuss on this who is this
for
is this for the church people is this
for the church crowd this is for
everyone before the children just for
the kids almost like nothing that all
your instincts follow your heart
no I [ __ ] with you you know dogs is way
a way to be it over glad I can make it
out here yeah I appreciate you coming
out and it's a nice day
it's got a room with no windows but it's
okay yeah yeah what you focusing on the
questions at hand because we're trying
to get out to the whole world because
you sir have a certain skill that
attracts the whole world I mean you're a
comedian that can really entertain
everyone all ages all races I mean is
that a skill you developed over time or
is that something you've done since the
beginning I mean I've always been pretty
good with people so I can always relate
to people and most of the time as long
as they know what you're talking about
you can usually make something funny so
I think I've been doing it for a while I
didn't know what I was doing like when I
was like a kid I would make people laugh
and I didn't really even get it like
what are you laughing at like why does
everybody not think like that everybody
should be asking this question once I
started doing comedy is something that I
kind of developed and just tried I mean
that's my main thing just make sure the
crowd knows what I'm talking about
there's audience know what I'm talking
about do they understand you know a I'm
not gonna talk to them about something
that they have no knowledge of you know
I might not go to the hoodies room and
do a long drawn-out Game of Thrones bit
you know what I'm saying I might not go
to the mainstream room and do a detailed
history of Gucci Mane's beef with jay-z
so you know it's just yeah did you start
off I know I hate that the the scene is
somewhat segmented and like you know
quote urban or quote mainstream did you
start on an urban side and then
kind of gravitate towards a quote
mainstream cider you always did both I
just did both because it was the best
way to give them out the most station so
when the first place that went up was
twisted taco so I mean that's kind of it
kind of blends together in Atlanta and
at the twister taco it could be
everything you know you would get your
mainstream people you would get the
urban people you would get some
alternative people were just weird so it
all kind of blended together there and
then the star part found I went up there
a lot and that's another place where
it's just like anything goes I've seen
some crazy things come through that door
so yeah but now I'd say that I started
to poke because it was the best way to
get the most station like I could you
know hit two stages in one night
possibly yeah and I'll do that right
yeah this stage is a stage so yeah I do
the same thing most most places I go I
think I can get off pretty much anything
same material pretty much yeah for the
most part I mean I might do a few
changes here and there just for what I
expect the crowd to know but yeah I mean
in younger crowds all the crowds are
different you know younger crowds
haven't had as much experience in life
so they don't understand a grown
person's point of view sometimes so and
all the people they don't understand the
young people's stuff so yeah so you just
got to find a nice little balance but
why do you think the majority of comics
struggle to find that balance because
you get comfortable you get comfortable
you get better by making yourself
uncomfortable by pushing yourself to the
limits pushing yourself out of the
comfort zone that's how you get better
people get comfortable man you get
comfortable it's like cheers everybody
knows your name you come in you know you
can go up I know I'm gonna be able to
get up here I've been you know I've been
here long enough but in the beginning
they treated you the same way they treat
everybody else who they don't know so
you forget that you had to build that
relationship and I think a lot of times
it's just you know you might go you
might not know anybody it's not your
comfort zone you're not comfortable
going you know if you if you do the
mainstream you're not comfortable doing
the urban stuff are going to the hood
because you feel like oh well they're
gonna or whatever stereotype you believe
in this same vice versa you go the
mainstream or they only want to hear you
know people
you know like they're not gonna
understand my struggle to wear it now
they understand what she's saying if you
say it's all and they know what you're
talking about so I think that comfort
zone you just gotta push yourself and I
mean you get around you do both you know
yeah yeah I mean another comic who
definitely pushes the envelope from a
comfort standpoint I mean Dave Chappelle
mm-hmm of course one of the best to ever
do it yeah and he's uh he's a beast I
got to you know work with him and seeing
him work and you know if you ever get to
see a masterwork or something just just
watch and like yeah you get to see you
get to see somebody who really just
drives the show and like do you think
you comfortable onstage you not not
until you seen him like you you not
you're not that comfortable okay who you
are for you're not that comfortable
onstage as comfortable as he is where I
still care like and yet Dave Dave
definitely cares about his craft in his
art but he doesn't care what that
audience has to say or their
expectations because he knows where he's
taking the show already so is yeah I've
heard him quoted as saying comedy as a
language that he speaks fluently I agree
yeah I'd agree yeah
how many shows did you get to see him
work oh I see it was six here's nine
total nine total yeah so when those nine
shows would each show be completely
different he's just speaking that
comedic language I mean there was things
like he would he might just change
change up stuff do it a little
differently you saw him you I'd like me
like I saw him experiment with stuff
none of it didn't work like not work you
know like all of it was like you go okay
well he did that this time okay so he
said that right there instead of say
that right and you and you're watching
and piecing together and as a comedian
who kind of has to do that with your set
but you might not get to watch somebody
do it back to back to back and see it
evolve it like oh okay
well how is he gonna change it up for
this audience and yeah so those but yeah
definitely a little bit different stuff
but he was mostly sticking you could
tell what he was going with like what he
had been working on
when he wanted to show to the people but
yeah there'd be little night of changes
and stuff so like on show one he would
maybe say a little bit about a certain
topic and then by Show 9 he has a fully
developed a bit no I mean he might say a
little bit about one topic and then buy
like you know show 9 you're like okay
well he he used that to lead into this
to make this point and it's all like I
mean he had some of the best stuff on
like just like uh
you know the stuff were you like oh I
wish we could've died I wish I could
have thought of that and like even like
at some point it's like he'll just take
questions from the crowd but you know if
so like people who say stuff like
somebody said black lives matter and
then somebody said all lives matter and
he's just like on the spot he was like
yeah but not all lives are being taken
and I was like it doesn't get much
better than a comeback there's like and
I'm like and that's I don't know I don't
know if he had that in the chamber or
wherever it came from but how it came
off was amazing so you know like yeah he
had people policing the audience at all
just well you just the security but just
that's for that's for footage but they
do that most people shows - so was there
any direct contact between you and
Chappelle or was this more of an
observation oh yeah no no tripel like he
knew who I was so that was cool yes that
was crazy he told me you know the forces
I heard the force is strong with you so
I'm like as a Star Wars fan and the Dave
Chappelle fan that was the coolest [ __ ]
you know I'm saying from Dave Chappelle
yeah that's you got to put that on the
resume yeah I mean that's I mean I
definitely took it like and I'm like
okay no like he said I'm good like no I
can throat choke you because he said the
first is like yeah but yeah Wow
so that what that was crazy and like it
was still kind of surreal like cuz I was
like my main thing was like I was really
watching just a lot of stuff cuz I'm
like this is somebody I watched before I
even thought about to a comedy like you
don't know saying it
like it's the court you strive to play
on you want to play on the same court
with Georgia you know I'm saying even if
it's a pickup game you know you just
want to hit your free throws grab a few
rebounds that's all I wanted to do and
make it you know he made that experience
possible so yeah she was cool I mean the
force is strong with you I must agree
from opening up with Chappell mm-hmm
after that experience doing nine shows
with Chappelle has that kind of boosted
the confidence to step out even more on
stage I mean yeah a little bit I don't
stop I like being on stage as much as
possible so I still get on stage so even
after I did that I had a show I came
back and it wasn't good if he does the
same so it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter what you did before what you did
previously those people don't know it
they don't care they weren't at the show
and you know part of it I still got my
jokes off but it just wasn't a good
overall set and so I'm like yeah that
kind of keeps you grounded so mm-hmm
you know the confidence is there and you
know what you're capable of but you have
situations like that they remind you all
right well you know one of the rooms you
go to and you got people sitting on the
stage with you and you know they're
taking selfies the whole time you know
people you know mm-hmm enjoy where you
at like you're not having a good time
and that's why y'all over here lonely do
you have comebacks in the chamber
especially local shows there are gonna
be people texting and whatnot do you
have jokes you go do to hammer them back
or is this all just spontaneous Oh
I mean you might have a few in the
chamber but I like to see what happens
because a lot of times people to set
this up they'll say something stupid
that you can play off of so and you
definitely have a improv background has
that helped your stand-up from a
creative side like developing jokes
onstage um I think it came before that
like I was really always kind of like
they're like more of this stuff was I
was more worried about doing comedy
because I was like I don't know how to
just make up funny stuff and be funny I
know how to play off a funny situation I
know how
you know comment on something and make
it funny
but I don't know how to just create but
then you know I learned how to do it so
I think it's something I've kind of been
doing for a while and not even realized
it and like now I mean the actin it
helps with the stand-up and the standup
helps with the act and they both fuel
each other but yeah I wouldn't say that
yeah improv stuff but I think I was
because when I first started doing
comedy I didn't really know what I was
gonna do I just get up there kind of
winging it so I think it's something
that's kind of been in me so never like
a pen to paper type of joke writing um
yeah now cuz you got it you got a like
hone their craft like you got to
remember what you said you gotta
remember how you got there even if it's
not writing it out verbatim whatever put
me in that mind escape to make that joke
that's what I need to write down and
that's what I need to remember but yeah
like when I first went up I didn't know
I didn't have jokes written I was just
like I'm just gonna go up and if I suck
it'll be alright cuz I'm just starting
so I was like you know I could suck in
the beginning you allowed to suck the
beginning and if I don't like it then
I'll just never do it again
so that was my thinking and I went up
and worked out do you have an example of
a joke where maybe you came up with it
on stage and you're like I need to
remember that you write it down and
maybe add to it so I'd like to know the
concepts come off stage or you find them
on stage and then you I mean it'll come
off stage like I know that once you
start doing a comedy you can't give
nothing away no more so if you're making
your friends and a half you make your
family laugh whatever that is you need
to figure out is it what what what about
that is making them laugh and how can I
show it to other people to make them
laugh the same way so like everything
like if I think it's funny I'm gonna
write it down if it sounds funny if I'm
listening to a song if I hear something
funny if I'm having a conversation with
somebody and they're laughing at the
[ __ ] that I'm like hold on let me type
this out you know I'm saying write this
down right quick come back to it I'm
trying to think of an example but not
I mean sometimes stuff just comes
onstage and it just it just fits like
well like last night for example closed
out the Improv you had a joke about
Oprah Winfrey oh yeah yeah yeah you've
never seen her in a movie with a
cellphone yeah yeah yeah you don't play
with any of those old movies yeah yeah
yeah because that's something was in the
moment because you also had jokes about
Will Smith in the movies and like he has
a clean haircut yeah it's gonna be an
action movie and if it's like an old
yeah he's not trimmed ugly but he
doesn't have a line Oh is gonna be a
tearjerker
yes Govi is gonna try to make you cry
mm-hmm
but I'm not the Oprah thing the over
there came from um just I have been
saying it for a while but I hadn't
figured out quite how to say it and I
was like you know Oprah's and I don't
want to see any more movies that Oprah's
a part of because she only likes the
struggle so I think like every movie
she's in times are bad for black people
and so I think that's how it started and
then eventually like I started like I
would be like you never see Oprah and a
futuristic thriller and then I was like
okay well how can I just play the people
that you know like I was like okay
Oprah's in them they never use cell
phone like you don't say there's no no
GPS in any movie Oprah's been in and so
then it just kind of evolved from there
and say you know yeah so do you think
that level of race awareness stems from
your time at Florida A&M I think it just
stems from being in the South period I
think like just in the South but you
always have and it's not even like being
serious all the time
but you always have to find the races
angle just because it's funny like just
because like like you don't wanna didn't
let him do that right because he's black
and you're like okay yeah like like you
have to do that like well that's it in
and just because like it's so much stuff
that was that way you know like it was
that way it was the whole Jim Crow era
and stuff so where things were like that
but I think just like black folks like
either you either you go cry about that
[ __ ] all the time
or you're gonna make light of it are you
gonna bring people's attention to it and
you gotta like deal with it and address
it like because people rather sweep it
under the rug so I'd rather just talk
about it and address it and be like yeah
now everybody's uncomfortable you see
see how everybody's are comfortable now
okay now let's get back to laughs but I
just want you all to know like it makes
you uncomfortable sometimes like black
people white people like sometimes like
Oh where's he going with this and yeah
you should feel like that Mike you know
what I'm saying and then when I get
there and you're still with me and
you're still laughs and then you're like
oh okay
yeah this [ __ ] is kind of stupid like so
yeah you seem to find a lot of comfort
in the discomfort of life where does
that stem from is that something that
was passed down at a genetic thing like
I mean I just think is it comes with
being on stage do understand though if
you don't get more uncomfortable than
that like I'm opening up my chest like
I'm showing like giving you a piece of
my soul every time I go up here and I'm
putting it in your hands what you do
with it like you could literally like
stomp this [ __ ] out of it every time and
but if I'm giving you that then you're
gonna have to take you're gonna have to
feel it too like I'd much rather you be
uncomfortable and maybe uncomfortable
like no it's not gonna all be on you so
like yeah sometimes they're digging
yourself out of a hole like it's just to
see like okay yeah you see how
uncomfortable you feel right now like
and it's also like a control thing like
I'm taking that back away from them like
yeah they're making me feel
uncomfortable even now I still like
onstage like it you know you get those
moments you like [ __ ]
is this working is it you know what [ __ ]
they'll like give me this y'all be
uncomfortable now I'm now only back
we're good good his balance been
restored as balance been restored now
that you're uncomfortable I'm
uncomfortable it negates itself now
everybody's comfortable let's go so yeah
I think it just comes from being
- like you can crumble yeah man like
it's easy to you know people who hold a
jokes hostage onstage like oh you're not
gonna laugh atom bomb I'll kill him I'll
kill another joke I'll kill another one
[ __ ] laugh
another one did alright he's holding his
own jokes hostages well have you had
material you feel like as you're
progressing and gaining momentum and
more exposure as they're certain topics
you're trying to steer away from now I
know early on for example there was a
lot of weed centric jokes do you feel
like that you're kind of past that point
now you know what it was crazy is like
yeah I had a lot I got a lot of weed
jokes I have a lot of we chose a lot of
people to tell me hey well you shouldn't
have you know you don't need to do so
much weave material or maybe don't do
the weed or maybe don't smell like weed
or maybe don't you know maybe don't
don't tell everybody about the way [ __ ]
and then you know or maybe you know cuz
you gotta have more than wheat material
and I'm like okay cool whatever but now
that shit's going legal everywhere it's
a multi [ __ ] billion dollar business
it's been that you don't knows that and
I'm like I [ __ ] I've been telling you
I've been saying that drug laws are
stupid I've been saying this and people
are like oh it's just weed material and
I'm like yeah but look where stuff is
going like I don't I don't really listen
to nobody
like I listen to what somebody has to
say and maybe if it applies I'll use it
but I don't know where your where your
thoughts are coming from like sometimes
where people tell you stuff like oh you
shouldn't do weed stuff okay is that
because they told you not to do it or is
that because you don't really smoke weed
cuz I do so you said I was talking about
what I don't and and if it's innovates
and and I think that's just is actually
made it easier for me to talk about weed
if anything to do it but yeah like I
still have those jokes but jokes just
grow like I don't use them may I use
them as needed but it's some stuff I
don't use and
some stuff gets left behind and some
stuff you keep yeah do you find weed
from a creative standpoint is it a
facilitator or an inhibitor I can be
both probably depends on type of person
you are
I'm like the weed doesn't stop me from
working spokesperson
that's what courtesy said in a song
that's how I feel like if it does this
if you can't do your job
hi I'm not sure that you can really do
your job so like I mean it's just wing
baby like like every job I've had I
probably been able to do like hi
but that's the best that's everything
but uh I think it can be a performance
enhancer but anytime something becomes a
crush like you needed to perform or you
needed to write you know you not in a
good spot that's you never want that
like if you need a drink you have to go
onstage drunk like you not gonna be able
to because and then weeds a thing like
you might not you not gonna bring it on
the plane you know so you might get to a
place and you don't have a contact there
you don't have you know you so you're
not gonna have week before the show but
are you gonna do freak out and just have
a bad show no you're just gonna do what
you do not for me but I can I can't see
it being you know if people smoke to get
too high before they go onstage and then
they not not about their life and you
know yeah it's gonna [ __ ] you up sit
down somewhere
mm-hmm drink some water have you found
yourself in moments where you have to
kind of check your consumption you're
like all right this is starting to kind
of get in the way a little bit
no I mean I'll probably say that if I
got pulled over so [ __ ] but no like it
usually doesn't get in the way and I'm
also kind of like I do like I go heavy
and then I'll stop you know just because
when I come back to it I'll be way
higher then I normally would some you
know I might go hard for three four
weeks and then she Oh for like two and
then come back and sometimes like when I
cheer like I don't even notice it it's
gone you make a pass some like if you're
a heavy heavy smokey make it past those
first four or five days and you good
well besides standup you also have
experience with acting most notably
house opinion I think was where you get
recognized the most I've been with you
when you've got recognized for that a
few times that is an atlanta-based
production for some reason in Atlanta
there seems they don't seem to be
drawing from this pool of talent we have
here why do you think that is I I don't
know man I don't know if they don't get
out I mean that the house the painting I
did I had the benefit of the casting
director coming to a comedy show so she
got to see what I actually knew so she
was one of those casting directors that
went out and actively sought talent on
Alpha Tyler that was her name and she
was I mean she was like you know she
came here Carden was like we'll keep you
in mind if we have anything that we
think you'll be good for and sometimes I
think that sometimes some of the a-town
talent just don't know how to
necessarily go about fitting into that
industry and being cooled about stuff I
found just um I mean cuz she came out
she gave her car to a number of people
when I went to read for the part pretty
much every black comedian I knew was at
the read so I'm already like at imitated
I'm like okay so from that I saw the
yeah she was full of people and I think
that they don't like a lot of the
casting directors that come through here
we're afterthought too like they did the
major cast in LA in New York so they may
have a few speaking lines a lot of extra
roles for the people here in Atlanta and
the people that can snows bigger parts
they're just not coming out to Atlanta
comedy shows they not there's nobody
telling them to look at this person from
Atlanta so from that industry side it's
not that and then from the comedian side
I think some people doesn't just don't
they don't know how it works like if you
exchanged numbers with one of these
caster people you can't be constantly
calling them blowing them up asking them
when is this gonna happen when am I uh
well you know you said that you would
get me up like you know that that means
nothing like somebody said you know hey
you in mind that's great they didn't
have to do that much but they don't owe
you anything
and if you think harassing them is gonna
get you in they're like no that's the
wrong route like and I think that's how
people are and I think people you know
sometimes like you don't get the role
and then you see the person out and you
like oh why you ain't give in there like
that's not really you know I'm saying
like what's for you is for you but don't
be uncomfortable to be around don't make
it uncomfortable to wear these people
don't want to work with you because of
harassment so I think it's it's
multi-layered I also think that some you
know some people just that their
approach is too aggressive and you want
to blow up overnight and that's not how
it happened it's like one thing's not
gonna make a break you is all the things
that you know I mean yeah you might have
one thing that's better than the other
but hopefully you're not a one-hit
wonder and you have something else and
you take a dip and then you come back
and you have something else oh yeah but
that's my take on it
have you been pursuing an agent or
management at this point um no I had a
manager before and it was cool but um
now I'm starting to look a little bit
towards agencies like outside of Atlanta
and stuff and I mean the main thing
about that is just you know you gotta
you gotta get on the radar some kind of
way so whether it be you know a decent
television appearance whether it be a
showcase maybe it's one of these
festivals maybe it's something you did
on the Internet
whatever it is you just gotta kind of
get on the radar and then keep plugging
at what you doing keep doing what you're
doing
realize that getting on the radar is not
the end goal that's like the first step
so yeah I've been reaching out
well you mentioned a lot of Atlanta
talent being an afterthought as far as
what the act in a stuffy like yeah so I
mean you've been steady in Atlanta I
mean you're obviously one of the top
comedians in the city do you find
yourself wanting to get out to these
bigger cities and surpass the
afterthought status I mean yeah just
because
I feel like now at this point I gotta
kind of bring it to them and it's like
you got to go ball on a home court so
for them to respect you you know they
can they can come here and they can see
you play and they can even you know play
on the same court with you but until you
come to de hometown and do it in front
of they fans and then they're like oh no
he's like yeah why you didn't so yeah
that's kind of how it was with New York
and New York the place I feel that just
makes you you know stronger as a
comedian because it's uncomfortable
place so I'm like back to that thing
it's just it's not it's not comfortable
it's you know you don't want to interact
with people will guess what now you have
to you don't have said like now you have
to all types of people all day like here
you can go and go a whole week and only
deal with the people that you want to
deal with and you don't really have any
interaction with but like New York is
like [ __ ] a crazy person right here in
your face yeah I agree with that
get off my face man all right old lady
try to help her with this [ __ ] she looks
like she's about to die do you know
there's a mic that you like throw this
dude a little change for playing the
piano in the subway cuz how the [ __ ] did
he get the piano in the subway which is
stuff you see you like who you brought a
whole drum set down here who helped you
like so yeah but you know they said New
York just this is a hotbed for talent
for a reason you know they say in New
York that's where you want to go if you
want to be great they say you go to you
know la Hollywood if you want to be
famous and I think you know the talent
like that I mean yeah I mean we are
doing this in a day care and you
apologize Clayton no it's all right man
I mean you got your hustles and we can't
all be opening up for Chappelle and
everything you know I don't know why
people say that like they bring me I was
like I mean it's a big honor and I know
he's a big dude but don't say that
before you bring me on stage they didn't
see me at the show no they're like oh he
thinks he's Dave Chappelle is that
that's all I think the audience
and I'm like no I don't know just but
then when you go up to New York and
you're surrounded by people that may not
be well known but are seasoned comedians
who can hit it night after night yeah is
that why you're leaning towards that as
opposed to LA because it's the talent
pool and yeah and I just know more
people in in New York too I know more
people up there and I know if you get up
there and you and you're just doing
those open mics like yeah that's that's
rough like three minutes number 27 on
the list and it's a roomful of comedians
and yeah it's not it's not you know
saying it's not fun so if you can't you
know if you can't get on some of those
better shows or shows where you can
actually get you know ten minutes you
know fifteen minutes seven minutes then
you know yeah it can be torturous so
you're trying to get more established
here and build your network before you
make the leap well no I think I think
the leaves coming like probably like
real soon like like this summer soon but
uh I mean I've been doing it probably
what 10 years now so and it's been here
and it's been based here and feel like I
mean I've been most places and it works
so I'm like I'll go somewhere else and
show y'all how much it works and we'll
see how much I'll appreciate it so well
your full-time is most of your comedy
income I'm what you call a
hunter-gatherer oh I'm more of a
Neanderthal just way like I just get
what I can't like uh-huh it's um once
I'm amazed at how much I'm making in
this month's where I'm like I haven't
made any money and I may starve but yeah
like well yeah I think that's that
that's on the that's on the table too I
think that's coming so yeah I think this
you're gonna be a good year I've been
feeling good out here so yeah yeah big
summer yeah yeah ten years in me yeah
yeah man I've been putting it down for
ten summers like jay-z was saying
where's the love
I do you feel like you're doing
everything you need to do on your end or
are there certain no no I don't do
everything I need to do about it like
it's a lot of stuff our problem I need
to I need to network more I need to be
better at that problem I need to kick it
I don't need to leave right after I get
done doing stuff but I'm not good at
doing that and you know I acknowledge it
I try to get better at it still don't
like doing it but I acknowledge I got to
do it you know let me see hold me back
just I don't like it I like it I don't
like heaviness you know like if I'm
hanging out with somebody cool and we
can't get it but to hang out for the
fact of meeting somebody and you know
needing to be in the yeah I'm just not
that person like if it's not really
comedy related like I got burned out on
the club and bars a long time ago and if
it's not comedy related I don't really
want he would be there to talk but yeah
and then stuff on my end like the social
media stuff like I got I gotta get
better at that like I feel like old man
with that [ __ ] like I don't get it like
well the talent levels there and there's
on your end
plenty of people I'm sure you've seen
the talents not there but they've got
the networking game locked down yeah
I've got millions of followers they're
gonna end up two months in there yeah I
respect anybody so so and however you
get it get it and that's what's cool to
me about it but I also think like
sometimes like you know those people got
to put in the work and I think people
are so quick to put people on this
higher status because of followers and
but I don't think that always translates
because you know Soulja Boy I got two
million followers but how much did this
last hour himself you know two million
of them people go out and buy he's out
are they really two million fans are
they too many people that just wanna
watch and see you know what's going on
in this celebrity's life you know so
yeah and stop booking these people that
you expect to do
our worth of time and all they've ever
done is 14 second videos like like some
of them can go some of them are give you
they got good little skits and there's
some people that make noise and they do
they thing but some of these people man
I don't don't expect them to be able to
do an hour by they self and they do 14
second videos after editing and
everything like don't expect that like
yeah
stack the show a little better maybe
personal comedians in there like it's a
few people try to do it right so mmm-hmm
we'll see I mean as a vet in the game do
you see that long-term hurting comedy or
is this just kind of like a fad that'll
pass can it hurt comedy it shouldn't
they're comedians keep doing what they
do and people respect what it is cuz I
think it hits a certain level and
there's people that I mean you have 2
million followers but what's the what's
the age range do at what level you know
so there's this room for everybody I
don't think that it could mess up comedy
I think you know you're gonna have
people that do what they do and they're
gonna get what they deserve it's some
people that's gonna make good off being
Instagram comedian or a vine comedian
and they're gonna transfer that into
more stuff and it'll be more acting and
that'll be their launching off point the
same way that it's gonna be comedians
that jump into acting or writing
whatever so I think it's room for
everybody
and I mean yeah I think a lot of folks
some of y'all not gonna make I mean
that's just it's just period that's an
anything like some folks just not going
you're not going to write even if you're
making it right now you're not going to
continue to make it like it just I mean
ask some other people that had one-hit
wonders like as you know they're like
well I feel confident in saying that you
were gonna make it I appreciate it man
I've already I really want to feel like
I made it for the most part like five
years without working a regular job
that's that's as much make it as I want
to thank you that's all I wanted to live
life as close to a rap song or a dope
dealer as I could without actually
selling dope
like with none of the risk and all the
benefits wake up when I want to be in
the club all night get paid for it by
so let people know where they can find
in seeking you can't find me don't don't
try to find me know it's talking about
the networking all right no Instagram
everything Facebook Twitter yeah
Clayton English on everything just
Clayton English one word maybe a space
on Facebook but yeah you know it's me
you'll see the picture of me let's see
what else am I gonna be doing
there's plugging that make you
uncomfortable what social media social
media is that making uncomfortable no
not really it's just I know I'm not
gonna be on there like this so I'm
telling y'all to go there and then I
feel like I have y'all waiting mm-hmm
and when I do put something y'all
respond y'all show love and I appreciate
it it's only about 140 of y'all that
show love but out of three thousand two
thousand whatever it is that's that's
okay with me
that's fine but yeah I don't really post
on this so but I'm gonna do better I got
some more stuff coming I'm about to get
a fan page I don't know what that is but
I'm gonna do it I'm filming some things
as well
I definitely been filming some stuff
that's probably all gonna drop like this
summer like I was just gonna have a
alright so this is what I'm doing I'm
cleaning out everything going through
the internet I'm picking up all the old
stuff getting rid of that and then this
summer I'm gonna drop all new content
just internet content though so yeah I
got a couple of series and might have a
cartoon in the works and yeah but yeah
I'm a social media yeah back to that I'm
um yeah I'm on there I'm on there I'm on
there more promise I don't know what
snapchat is but I don't think I'm gonna
get it is there anything else you want
the world to know yeah man um I want the
world to respect this ATL comedy Joe
that's what you doing that's why we here
right mm-hmm
well I must say it's it's been a
pleasure to have one of the patriarchs
of the Atlantic comedy scene on the show
I don't know if there's I don't know if
that's accurate that we know like father
did or something like I've just been a
part of it it's just been going on a
long time well how has it evolved since
you've been in it
it's evolved man it's a lot more people
create their own stuff now but I realize
that before I started doing comedy the
scene was pretty I mean it was pretty
new I mean you really only had the
punchline and like uptown the old uptown
as far as like comedy clubs and then
places they did comedy were scattered
and around but they weren't paying
comedians money a lot of bringer shows
you know it bring people bring your
friends it's $10 for them to get in and
then we'll give you 10% of the door or
20% of the door I'm like that's dumb I
could just ask my friends for $10 a
piece and they would give me that and
that would be maybe like I'm helping the
dream but yeah so you say all these old
shows have gone away but have been
replaced by that many more yeah yeah
they've been replaced own and then it's
stuff that's been going a long time
since I've started you know well it's a
pleasure to have one of the forefathers
it's a star saying [ __ ] like that
pleasure to have one of them a race
Stone Mountain Inn put me and a few
other [ __ ] on there they not it
is not the forefathers don't say that
about is this dope but I don't think I'm
a 4/5 I don't want to be old yet like no
you're young and that's what's great
about the Atlantic comedy scene it's a
young scene but we have all this talent
yeah we do we do we do I agree so I
appreciate being part of this I
appreciate you making me a part of this
man you already know man we worked
together couple times man we've had
we've had some adventures we survived no
we made it thank you I look forward to
the future and this summer yeah yeah
let's do it
there's something you know what it is
July 22nd I can't say what it is but
it's what it is
Thank You Clayton English Joe Byers [ __ ]
with me man you know what it is
appreciate you
[Music]